good evening and welcome to that guy
riffs
today the other guy joins that guy again
as we take a look at a film about lunch
room manners because there was really
nothing else to talk about back then sit
back and enjoy again remember when you
asked your kid what they did today and
they said nothing this is the nothing
they're talking about
because it's the 1950s and we haven't
acknowledged that drugs exist yet
millions of tax dollars and five PhDs to
tell you how to eat lunch just before
lunch one day a puppet show was put on
at school it was called mr. bungle goes
to light this was not planned and the
children were terrified it was fun to
watch
yay in the bar that kind of show they're
gonna point to that puppets crotch at
any point I'm out of here hands his
hands were dirty dirty and his hair was
messy messy but mr. bungle didn't stop
to wash his hands or comb his hair he
went right to life you fool mr. bungle
you fool God he'll kill us all
then instead of getting into line at the
lunch Merry Christmas kiss my ass kiss
his ass heavy on side and went right to
the front even though this made the
children laugh no one thought that was a
fair thing to do
stop laughing God telling I'm a serious
puppeteer then in the lunchroom mr.
bungle was so clumsy and impolite that
he knocked over everything and no one
wanted to sit next to it this is the
worst last supper ever and when he
finally knocked his own tray off the
table that was the end of the puppet
show for the puppeteer had died the
children knew that even though mr.
bungle was funny to watch he wouldn't be
much fun to eat with Phil knew that mr.
bungle wouldn't have many friends he
wouldn't want to be like mr. Vong phil
was having a spasmodic attack later miss
Brown said it was time for the children
who ate in the cafeteria to go to lunch
she hoped there weren't any mr. bungles
in this room Susie you have bungle
written all over you apparently the kids
took a vow of silence filled stop to
return a book to Miss Brown while his
friends went onto the lunchroom he would
have to catch up with them later Phil
realized this was an incredibly
pointless scene and should have been
edited out on his way to catch up with
his friends Phil almost walked past the
boys room but he stopped and thought
were his hands clean no they were a
little dirty and bloody Phil remembered
that mr. bungle didn't wash his hands
mister bungles hair was messy too Phil
didn't want to be like
mr. bungle the se-young Larry Craig
begins his descent inside the boys room
Phil was surprised to see some of his
friends washing their hands two in the
urinal for some reason Phil washed his
hands well with lots of soap guys Howard
Hughes didn't use that much then he
rinsed the soap off dirty dirty I'm a
dirty little boy now somebody watch my
crotch Phil dried his hands well too
when he was finished he threw the paper
towel in the basket where it belonged
and then he made sure that his hair
looked neat what here shall we Brown had
more hair than that now Phil and his
friends were ready for lunch
his germ-free bubble was waiting for him
in the hall yeah you're welcome but
holes there was a line of children
waiting to get into the lunchroom when
Phil got there fucking rush hour he saw
some boys he knew at the front of the
line they waved for him to go up to the
front with them that's that fucking do
it do it now Phil didn't want to break
into line as mr. bungle day thou shalt
not bungle so Phil went to the end that
was the fair thing to do
he would see his other friends inside
the lunchroom if I don't starve first
the line moved very fast and soon Phil
was inside first he picked up his tray
and and toughie suspense is killing me
ever get his lunch then he got his
silverware he put his knife fork and
spoon neatly on the tray that's just OCD
and then he slid his tray along he began
with his left foot then his right foot
then his left foot then his right foot
he always enjoyed looking at the good
food in the cafeteria it tasted good and
was good for him too he lost his taste
buds in the war instead of having a
sandwich today Phil decided to take the
hot lunch which was cold because he
didn't cut in line Phil took some bread
and butter too and he knew what else he
wanted Dana
Lala but Alice took the last carton on
the tray that's scratching or maybe
there was more milk so he said may I
please have some milk yeah of all yes
it was get you some milk or they throw a
pile of mashed potatoes in your face
escandarian yes there was more milk
um rejoice Phil remembered to say thank
you when he took the carton of milk like
I care he'll had good manners get out he
didn't want to be like mr. bungle in the
lunchroom and look at you Jimmy Phil
didn't want to forget his dessert
the King would you like some meal with
your cake at the end of the line the
lunchroom supervisor said she had
noticed how polite Phil was and she
smiled at him
she wouldn't smile at a mr. bungle that
smiling at you bungle Brazil went to the
table where his friends were he put his
tray down carefully pulled out his chair
quietly and sat down he knew his friends
wouldn't like a noisy mr. bungle at
their taste don't seems very anti bungle
there was someone fell like Freddie he
always brought his lunch from home it
looked good Freddie had a sandwich
an apple a cookie and milk and a small
spherical goat turd before Phil began to
eat he always put a napkin on his lap so
did Freddie hello truly everyone liked
Freddie he was very polite for example
if he had food in his mouth when someone
talked to him he always took time to
chew the food with his mouth closed and
swallow before he answered the fire
extinguishers over there Phil noticed
how straight and tall Freddie usually
sat Freddie kept his feet on the floor
too as opposed to up Phil's ass Phil
would rather be like Freddie than like
mr. bungle got it another polite person
everyone liked was Alice for example
when Alice sneezed she covered her mouth
Oh
protected her friends at the table from
any germs now they're all in her lap
while Phil and his friends ate a boy ran
past their table you shouldn't run in
the lunchroom only mr. bungle would do
that crucified upon flying him by his
own clean hands
Phil and his friends wouldn't like to
have a mr. bungle at their table then
lunchtime wouldn't be as much fun as it
is hey Phil ate slowly and enjoy
his lunch finally he had eaten
everything except his dessert which
would take him an hour he saved his cake
for last only a mr. bungle would eat his
dessert before he had finished the rest
of his lunch and Phil wasn't a mr. bung
he put his hands on the cake Crucifier
Chris fireman Phil drank his milk
carefully some children are messy when
they drink milk only he who shall not be
named drinks milk sloppily as each of
Phil's friends finished they didn't
leave the table but waited for all the
others to finish eating - even though
the bell rang 10 minutes ago
Phil was the last one done he wiped his
mouth and hands carefully with his
napkin
then he cleaned the table where he sat
he didn't want to leave his place at the
table dirty and not a bungle I'm not a
bungle everyone at the table cleaned his
own place well but look at that table
smell a bungle it was left very messy Oh
Phil vada mr. bungle must have sat there
bungle seems to be the Judas of the
puppet world but Phil didn't want to be
like mr. bungle I'd rather die so he put
his chair neatly into place and his
table looked fine he licked it clean
himself not a piece of paper or scrap of
food was left on it mr. bungle would
leave a pink cigarette on the bed before
he left
no mr. bungle sat here actually I'm
under the table Phil's friends were
careful to put their waste papers and
empty milk cartons where they belonged
in this way they helped keep the
lunchroom clean and it plugged up yet
another landfill phil was certain that
mr. bungle wouldn't put his paper in the
wastebasket and his empty carton on the
milk tray mr. bungle probably wouldn't
bother to put his lunch tray in the
right place either but Phil and his
friends did fuck mr. bungle fuck him in
the ass
lunch was good today Pongo Pongo Bob and
then Miss Brown told Phil and his
friends how proud she was of n they had
left their table the neatest in the
lunchroom no one here was a mr. bungle
and no one wanted to be suffer you Susie
cat dammit are you like mr. bungle mr.
bungle is ashamed
cause he spoils lunchtime what did I
ever do to you don't be like mr. bungle
have good lunchtime manners and lunch
will be more fun for everyone
seriously what I do was the bird
crossing my yard really necessary and
why was it made of both cartons what is
your deal I will not slip quietly into
the night cowards cowards